Chances are you probably
have a Facebook account.
You might have a Twitter account.
You might have a LinkedIn.
You probably have several accounts
spread across several different social
networking sites and you use them for
a lot of different purposes.
You might use one to keep
up with family and friends.
You might use one for job networking or
when to find new media to consume.
More and more people are actually using
social networking in education as well.
There are teachers in middle and high
school that are using Facebook in their
classroom or using Facebook
to extend their classroom.
They figure, if my students are on
Facebook every evening anyway,
why don't I give them
assignment notifications there?
Why would I host my
discussions on there?
Why don't I meet my students where they
are and try and bring the educational
experience to them, as opposed to
convincing them to come get it from me.
But there are others that suggest
that this isn't the best approach.
That by trying to integrate education
with something like Facebook, we're
watering down education, or we're trying
too hard to make education artificially
cool and really, we're losing some
of the real value in education.
So these are some of the issues
that we're going to wrestle with in
this lesson.
We're going to talk about whether or
not education and
social networking should
actually be integrating this way.
Should we try and
use Facebook for education?
use Twitter for education?
Or can we actually build new tools or
build new communities that
blur the line between social networking
and education, while also preserving
some of that sanctity or some of that
rigor to that educational environment.
Things like EdModo that
are custom built for
education but also have a lot of social
networking type features in them.
So, we'll talk about these
different tools and these different
questions that are available in
the community during this lesson.